okay believed Asian we are giving away a
30-minute private coaching session
one-on-one with you and Grant Cardone
and a 30-minute private coaching session
one-on-one with you and Tom bill you as
well as my Flex the ex 2019 calendar to
help you stay focused on your most
important goals this is a pretty
exciting video we're gonna end up giving
over a hundred thousand dollars worth of
prizes away on this tour and we're gonna
explain how you can get those prizes
so I'm doing a 23 City tour of the u.s.
we're gonna hit a new City basis every
four days it's called the believe tour
2019 I'm helping turn people from
figures into doers to help you turn
yourself doubt into unstoppable self
belief we're gonna spend three hours
together in each city and it's gonna be
an intimate interaction it's gonna be me
and a small group of entrepreneurs who
are in your city or coming from maybe
somewhat far away who knows this is a
turning point this is not just me
sitting at the front of every room
talking this is you taking action we are
going to take action together you're
gonna come out of these three hours
having taken action that may be
something you've been sitting on for
three months is actually now gonna
happen we're taking the 595 rule how to
spend five or seni time planning and
ninety-five percent of your time doing
it I'm going to teach you how to not get
yourself against judgments you stop
caring so much aware that people think
about you that are holding you back to
do the things that you should be doing
pick Teemo Teemo and also teach you how
to schedule for success so you don't
feel like you just on this hamster wheel
constantly moving moving moving moving
moving moving spending a lot of time
working but feeling like you're not
making progress so that's the main goal
and then and then doing Q&A where
whatever most important questions you
want to bring that you want help with
we're gonna make sure that that happens
in each city so that's the tour will
talk about the prizes the one I want
Grant Cardone the 100 um bill you the
flex calendar but first the big update
coming from Nina Caroline we have the
location or Pittsboro ready yeah you
guys know we I have picked the places
for Columbus Cincinnati sinaloa Indiana
Indiana Paula's honest apád Indiana okay
so yeah so we it's not updated under
invent it but I will get it update
tomorrow well by the time this comes out
the let's see oh yeah yeah yeah we've
committed to going to the 23 cities but
we don't have an exact venues in each
city yet yeah that's that's we talking
about showing those four cities we now
have venues by hotels hotels most of
most of them are hotels the one in
Cincinnati would not do tell you because
Convention Center it's like a commission
center
convention okay I like it it's about 20
minutes away from the downtown okay what
else
Wow okay so if you have questions
suggestions then the email tour at
america.com
Nina picks it up be nice and she's
hopefully nice too in their responses no
nice do nice same time Kenna Nina okay
let's talk about prizes so we have some
prizes that you get everybody everybody
who buys a ticket guys we have some
prizes that are for each city some lucky
people will get and we'll have some
prizes that are brand prizes at one
person for the entire tour guess I'm
free now self entreprises
everybody comes gets a coaching session
Lilly three people who come to each city
will get the private two-hour session
with me one person who's local and two
people whoever comes the farthest so for
those of you traveling I want to reward
you the two people who come the furthest
from the location in each city gets to
have that one on three two hour two
hours over said right yes to our coffee
shop meet up with me - then go even
deeper on the issues you've got and then
what would the grand prize is we've
announced so far oh I'm free ticket to
my free ticket to mine my event in May
on how to make money from you right
tennis $2,000 guys it's not like $2,000
it is $2,000
it is a $2,000 ticket spending time with
me and my team and 15 people from around
the world for three full days if you
want to do what I do in your industry
basically a thought leader make money
from books videos social media brand
deals all that kind of stuff
well worth it yeah that's that's insane
that's yeah and then the other grand
prize oh six months of coaching with me
I'm totally cap six months monthly call
with me to help you stay accountable
move forward big massive progress in
your business that's what we've
announced today the announcements are
two more grand prizes so the half an
hour session with tom bill you if you
don't know tom he runs impact theory he
built a billion-dollar business in quest
nutrition the quest bars and other other
products thomas based out of California
and you're gonna go and see him for half
an hour will likely Selma to you want
extra exposure for the YouTube channel
so being on my channel and you get to be
time do you to ask whatever you want
whatever questions you want about
building the business make that
connection with him and he's gonna coach
you for half an hour
he doesn't do coaching as a business so
this is a priceless opportunity to spend
spend some one-on-one time and then
repeat same thing with Grant Cardone if
you don't know grant he's in real estate
he's got half a billion dollars worth of
real estate he has a bunch of books he's
got his 10x conference both grant and
Tom are successful youtubers as well
producing tons of content featured them
on my channel whole bunch and grants
gonna sit with you for half an hour and
same deal whatever questions you want
would like to have our film guys they're
filming at 2:00 so you get promotion my
YouTube channel and he doesn't sell
coaching time either so for these guys
the the one-on-one time like time is the
biggest asset and so you're taking half
an hour at their time to spend that
one-on-one connection with the mentor
and I'm super pumped and they both given
their time too
as the grand prize for one lucky winner
so that's super excited to announce we
got more grand prizes coming but that's
what we're announcing this week and then
the flex the X is a tool that I use to
help me stay consistent on your habits
so you pick a habit that you want to
make sure that you're consistent on and
then you have a calendar that you every
day that you do the activity you exit
off the calendar and the goal is you
don't you don't break the chain you
always have an X like every day you flex
the Act you that the goal you cross out
the calendar and you do it again the
next day you do it again the next thing
you do the 12 years old Uncle Evan how
do I make sure that my stretch every day
that was her cool I have to stretch
every day so I do I can do the splits
greatly flex the X here's the counter
printed ah everybody do it and she's
doing it and it's surprisingly simple
but massively effective and something
that everybody who comes gets a PDF
version of the exact calendar that I use
myself so that you can stay consistent
on most important habits that you are
trying to build to so those are part of
the hundred thousand dollars worth of
prizes were given away on this tour
hopefully we'll see you guys in one of
the CDs or maybe multiple cities really
we should have some fries or someone who
comes to two of them I'll think about
that
think about that great if you guys have
questions let me know and we'll answer
them in a future video so let's get to
last week's questions and assume people
are saying and you get our reaction so
you want to say into your questions for
next week put them in the comments below
and we'll do our best and let's see what
we got from last week I live in Zambia I
wish I could attend one day hashtag
believe listen Zambia you're gonna have
you come from Zambia you're pretty I'm
pretty sure you're gonna win that that
bonus coffee session with me what
becomes the farthest I want to reward
the hustlers the people who put their
goals ahead of their convenience
accomplishing your goals will meet you
have to do things that are not
convenient for you for the people who
want to learn from a mentor that may not
be coming to your city go to that don't
learn from them put your goals ahead of
your convenience and I want to reward
those people and get the coffee shop
meet up so
come from Zambia come from your country
come from out of state come make it
happen
you're gonna win kourosh heaven just
push the Los Angeles ticket amazing
cohosh it before the meeting you super
excited that can't wait to meet you and
the other amazing believers love it
ulema the energy is real Jaime says all
caps Miami Jaime come to one of the
other 23 cities all caps back action
let's go goals ahead of your convenience
make it happen
doctor said if you're from Asia would
you win the six months when a prize this
is great every year Truman is still cold
you thinking about coming to Atlanta
we're at hard labor snows and defrost
your place to stay if you come so so the
the person who comes from the farthest
away in each city doesn't get the that's
not where the six months comes from six
months one on one with me is is for one
person as a grand prize across the
entire event same thing with the Grant
Cardone sitting with the ticket singing
with the Tom bill you that's one person
for the entire tour the the benefit of
coming from out of state or far away out
of country is the coffee shop meet up so
we have we have our event happening on
on one day the the calendar is up on the
tour then in most cities two days later
I'm going to be doing a two-hour coffee
shop meet up in a private location with
three people and one person is a random
person from the city and two people are
whoever came from the furthest away so
that's what you get you get to spend the
two hours with me and two other people
at a coffee shop and what good people
whatever problems you want to go through
cold and snowing yes we're going through
the cold in the snow come join us
you know it's too hot Atlanta come join
us and in cool off a bit and get
inspired to motivate along the way nice
EJ just got my ticket I'll see you in
Cincinnati I love it EJ we will see you
in Cincinnati that's a number two spot
no class since a number three spot
Society I love it EJ looking forward to
meeting you I've made some excellent
progress on my own but I want to
completely transform myself I love it
and it go to Garrett's for the popcorn
good any food recommendations email tour
at Ivan chemical calm I'll put in the
comments Nina will pick it up
what are you doing he's licking her gear
you let team Alex Lee just Anna's here
oh he says we said his name she got
yesterday okay here it sports very what
okay here it's popcorn in insanity and
yes EJ looking forward to meeting you
there it's gonna be exciting and this is
it right like it doesn't mean that you
saw right like he's made progress right
you can you can make progress on your
own but when you're around people when
you're around somebody who's who's done
more than you and you can learn from
them but also in a group of people who
want to hustle and push him forward I
think that that helps so many people
because chances are at least mostly
entrepreneurs that I've met that I know
you don't have a fantastic support
network you might be the only crazy
person who's doing this thing and
everybody else has a job and telling you
play safe and or they're supportive of
your ideas but they don't know what to
do they're not pushing hard themselves
and so that's part of the point to be
around other people too who want to want
it
yeah here with your last September
workshop people think you want to leave
they want to stay together yeah but
doesn't crying like they're leaving and
you want it but to be around people who
want it makes such a big difference and
so it's it's three hours but it's
life-changing so I'm super pumped to
meet you EJ and let's make it happen
next
sunshine Susie 90 for your hoodie is
black and gold I think I think last
weekend had the other good not the one
with the yeah yeah but I had like the
one with the the other hoodie the more
super gold one new hoodies black and
gold and those are Pittsburgh's official
city colors haha Pittsburgh Steelers
football that's true that's true you
should go to Pamela's for breakfast
just curious I know it's a good does it
okay I'm gonna a last president the US
flu Pamela to the White House to make
pancakes all right your muscles
wondering all I've had is coffee so far
today so that's impendence make its
leadership with Mike I literally saw you
yesterday in Toronto Airport I don't
want to bother you but it was cool to
see you
almost a moment because I was thinking
about taking a promotion
work then I thought if she focused on my
channel I saw you when it's like well
there's my answer LOL of it yes listen
but you know I just we just did we went
downtown yesterday and went to a
bookstore and we got stopped by five six
different people just saying hi like but
there are other people who then post it
on Instagram said oh I think that's a
come and say hi I love it this it's the
best for me I love I love saying hi I
love taking a quick selfie you know
probably put you up on my Instagram I
love it like I do the work right now I'm
just talking to a camera but I do the
work because I love the people I love
helping entrepreneurs and so putting
faces behind the numbers so X thousands
of people watch the video but like oh
you know Mike might watch this video
that's that's the best for me so it
doesn't have to take long it doesn't
mean I'm gonna since then we're gonna
spend 45 minutes talking about something
but quick 2 minute hi
take a picture thank you hug it out
that's still awkward for me I'm getting
used to it I don't do handshakes anymore
I'm trying to I'm trying trying to hug
I'm so give you a hug but yeah say hi if
you see me anywhere
say hi it's the best for me I love it
you can say hi to Nina if you see her
too and I love it Mike and good luck
good luck on your channel pumped nice
sunshine Susy oMG I want to meet you
Nina oh I want to meet you and Nina you
lost yesterday yes I did a polo means
you're going us today of we both wore
the same buddy we're doing again today
I said who wore it better aventure Nina
and Nina destroyed me she destroyed me
well these people know that if they vote
for me you'll be happy too happy lion no
honey why happy life no happy husband
happy happy what Brandon Boone guys help
me out give me something next week leave
it in the comments
the husband happy fire give me something
fire to be happy life happy wife happy
life anyway I got destroyed in the pool
mean the war better anyway it's fun okay
I want to meet you and Nina I love pits
for two I will thank you in advance love
it
see you there come on out school of rock
stars hi having any plans to come to
Austin Texas No so come to one of the
other cities what we're not that far
from Austin what's the closest we're
coming up we're coming close I don't
know if it's like if Phoenix is closer
or or New Mexico maybe New Mexico
Albuquerque Utah no Utah's too far I'll
look her yeah I think
Albuquerque's find the closest
Albuquerque or Phoenix anyway come come
come the Pittsburgh and wind let's spend
two hours together on the two days later
at the coffee shop come guys your goals
over your convenience Dan bar I'm
convinced regarding about the ticket yes
11 count me in for three coffee talks
for three coffee times Wow
well Dan bar listen you better come to
three different cities then if you go to
New Mexico though you might the other
Creek you went to get the coffee shop
Cynthia I think you're keeping fingers
crossed I'm going to the LA event I love
it I'm coming from out of state yes
Cynthia yes I love that come from out of
state
yes I love Cynthia already this is great
Phil Orange County California we're
coming to California we're doing five
stops in California I don't know which
one Orange County's the closest to but
what do we have la go
San Francisco Sacramento and then San
Jose San Jose Elijah I will give you
guys a prize to become the Brazil Eliza
come to San Jose it's gonna be fired
sasquatch one where's your tour go to
Evan Carmichael calm slash tour that's
for the tour's going looking forward to
meeting you I don't
hey how about Ohio I hope
sell tickets out of Ohio we're coming to
Cleveland it's at the end of the tour
Ohio we have so many club that's
Columbus Columbus Cincinnati and England
Wow hi Celine are you John or FEMA
that's pretty good I mean I know those
she's kind of disrespecting Houston
Texas and San Jose but she knows her
Ohio okay I listen dude we got three
cities help us sell tickets everywhere
Cincinnati and Columbus at the beginning
closest a Columbus number to Cincinnati
over 370 Minister last is it the very
last so Cleveland is 23 so 2/3 and 23
come on Adam we love you sell some
tickets
appreciate you sherry you should promote
this tour as a Christmas gift at this
time of year people know someone who is
starting their own business and support
they should attend to or 2019 so we're
dia everybody if you're looking for a
fantastic Christmas gift or yourself why
don't I give a gift to yourself I feel
like we don't give enough gifts to
ourselves okay so that's great and or a
friend of yours who is an entrepreneur
who could badly use this the believe to
2019 is a ticket for youth what else the
Halloween Chihuahua cool I'm gonna click
the link to see your tour dates you and
Nina made me a believer that there is
someone out there that will match your
personality and is possible for me to be
in a relationship thank you Wow
you know entrepreneurship and in
relationships are hard but it's
definitely doable it's just working
through it I mean it's one of the things
we're going to talk about how to
schedule for success right how about how
to not just build a business but build a
life whatever that life looks like like
your actions have to map to your
ambitions so looking forward to meeting
you giving you a hug
Nina wants to meet you too howling
Chihuahua she loves dogs but ours just
him is just a little bit bigger than the
Chihuahua
as a chihuahua no I think she's just
bigger anyway looking forward to meeting
you Davonte come to Orlando
Devante you should come to any of the 23
cities were going to goals over
convenience let's go to Vontae Zeno I
thought the coming tour was all right
the believe tour makes a lot more sense
it's just a better name yeah I mean at
the beginning when I started this it was
just a fun thing to do like maybe a
coffee shop meet up and see who shows up
but become was was Danny's one word my
video guy is coming with us
it's me dating the tour but now became
something much bigger and believe just
make more sense Benny I'm from New
Jersey
would love to see you enjoy see lol Joey
C is just how to say it with an accent
Jersey Joe easy Benny bring you joy Z to
Pittsburgh or Columbus or San Jose I
want to meet you goals over convenience
Chrissy love the balance of YouTube when
you find your partner and then your
purpose in life
Wow inspiring hashtag power couple
hashtag believe Nina support is awesome
she always wants to help she you know
she's not you know we can go out and
start your own business if I kind of do
something like this but but he always
wants to support what I'm doing he's
always try to help always wants to
contribute and so that's super helpful
the hardest part for me is is sharing
stuff because by default I don't I don't
want to share I don't need to share I
don't need if I'm working with through a
problem I don't need to share with
anybody to solve it I have to have to
sit by myself and figure it out but but
Nina wants to know like what's happening
sharing is caring for Nina see for me
it's not you know I don't share it is
not caring for me but Sharon is Karenina
so I have to make an effort to explain
what I'm doing what I'm going through
what I'm working on because it it helps
mean I feel closer to me even though for
that stuff doesn't really matter so I
have to like make it considered after
they do it so you figure like you figure
that and that's one of the hot sands for
us alright
the big announcement done today guys was
again be will the wind 30 minutes
one-on-one time with Tom Billy you 30
minutes one-on-one time but Grant
Cardone and everybody who comes gets a
flex DX calendar to help you stay
consistent and focused on whatever most
important habit you are trying to build
you get the common bull up not just to
something you're gonna learn it's gonna
be an amazing event right it's not just
hey a fan event Meetup like this is not
just tell me and take a picture get
inspired you're doing work in the event
we're making progress on your goals
together in the event you're gonna be
doing stuff in the three hours that we
are together because you need to build
momentum it's not just about coming and
being inspired and then that day you go
home and you're on fire you the next day
you wake up and and you're back to
normal you know like you vlog where
where did I'm gonna miss you go momentum
must happen this event must be a turning
point that's the bar going in you need
to come out with more momentum than when
you came in and yes and take a selfie
and have fun and meet other people and
you get to see me right that's worth
that's what the ticket price I would do
that no joke it's great that surprised
something I should put that as like
grand prize everybody wins
at the scene you know cool well guys
check out the link in the description go
get your tickets what's that really
excited to meet you
no jokes like this is there's a lot
going into this and that like I really
deeply care that you come out of every
event with with change that like this is
the turning point for you that you're
ready for something greater you're ready
to go off and stop doubting yourself and
stop worrying about other people's
opinions and actually take massive
action on accomplishing your goals 2019
has to matter that this event has to
matter in your city and an employ
everything I've got into you to make
sure that you make progress that's from
the heart like that's that's real that's
love and I spend way more time with
people than I probably should because
it's super important to me that our time
together matters and that you make
progress on your goals
so to get a ticket check the link is it
there's the link there in the
description and we look forward to
seeing you in one of the cities that
we're making a stop on oath also just
click here click thanks to us yeah yeah
yeah just click over there click there
there's a link there he'll buy your
tickets there we'll see you soon
much love believe